wait Bob don't you want to hear who wins  for Best Actor no I want to hate them  all equally he never gets out of  character does he for the best  performance by an actor in 1965 nominees  are  Oscar Verner in Schiphol fools Richard  Burton in the spy who came in from the  cold Rod Steiger in the pawnbroker  Laurence Olivier in Othello and Lee  Marvin in Cat Ballou the winner is  Lee Marvin  thank you thank you all very much I  don't want to take up too much of your  time there's too many people to  correctly thank for my career I think  though that half of this belongs to a  horse someplace on the dock  yes  yes sir I want him to know I'm as happy  for him as I would be for myself so much  Brinson sir